المباشره همم كان هناك استقبال حشد
للمنتخب المغربي والان توجه الى القصر
الملكي والعهل المغربي يستقبل اعضاء
الفريق ولابد انه
يحييهم فردا فردا واللفت والجميل والمؤثر
جدا جدا ان كل لاعب معه والدته همم
منتخب همم
في التقاء وتكوين
الان يدخلون برفقتي والدتهم الى قصر
الملكي للقاء العاهل المغربي وطبعا تقديم
التهنئه
من الجميل لحظ جهود المراه والامهات في
تربيه هكذا نجوم
[موسيقى]
يدخلون الان مع امهاتهم الى القصر الملكي
المغربي العاهل المغربيه يقفوا
تحيه والسلام عليكم
همم كل الحسود المغربيه والافريقيه
والعربيه
للمفاجات التي قدمها المنتخب المغربي في
همم هذا المونديال
يتم تقليد
اعتقد ان هو مدرب الفريق
او احد اداري الفريق احد اداري الفريق وكل
لاعب 24 لاعبا دخل برفقه والدته
هذا المدرب هذا مدرب المنتخب المغربي
فعلا مشاهد مؤثره
وليد الرجراجي هو مدرب الفريق المغربي مع
والدته يصافحان العاهل المغربي
وطبعا يتم تقليد المدرب في هذه اللحظات
يعني هي نوع من لاحظ جهود هذا الفريق
مع انه يعني لم يصل الى
المركز الاول ولا الثاني ولكن وصل الى
مركز الاول في قلوب العرب
والافارقه وكل من يعني يشجع هذا الفريق